welcome to the 2018 NBA Finals it's once
again the Golden State Warriors vs. the
Cleveland Cavaliers
for the sixth time in a row it's the
Golden State Warriors and the Cleveland
Cavaliers and after having no real help
in years LeBron is finally said [ __ ] it
I'll play them all by myself
well we've got a rematch once again but
this time the OE Stock Warriors will
face LeBron and his new teammates
genetically engineered clones of himself
even president Dwayne the rock Johnson
is excited to be here
and for the 14th year in a row its
Cleveland versus Golden State LeBron
James of course underwent a
controversial exoskeleton graft over the
offseason to become a terminator
whose teammates say quote he's more
machine now than man
in still Cavs warriors again literally
no one is happy about it
it's brawny James and his father versus
Riley curry in the still unfair least at
Golden State Warriors
and due to the impending apocalypse the
Golden State Warriors were what is left
of them has made the dangerous journey
across the badlands
in order to do battle once again and
look uncle drew is back oh wait sorry no
fishes tell old Kyrie Irving is now and
now we settle in for the national anthem
to be sung by the cryogenically frozen
head of Fergie